hello readers let's talk about themes
and how authors can intentionally build
messages into fiction now to recap a
little themes link big ideas about the
world we live in with the action of a
text for example in the Lord of the
Rings stories and films The One Ring
represents absolute power and how
dangerous that is how do we know that
though how did j.r.r tolkien as an
author develop that theme in the text
how can we go deeper beyond that
headline of the ring equals you know the
dangers of absolute power good readers
can look at a whole text from beginning
to end and identify where the author
purposefully chose words included
details or directed action that develops
or reveals the overall theme it's not
just that characters say oh no the Rings
super dangerous in fact I believe in the
Fellowship of the Ring gandalf says no
with that power i should have power to
great and terrible and over me the ring
good dana power still greater and more
deadly do not tempt me the characters
say that they do but it's also about how
they behave around the thing it's how
the plot is shaped around this object
and how a group of people come together
to identify this ring as a dangerous
magical artifact that needs to be
destroyed for the good of the world it's
not just dialogue it's also descriptions
by the author and actions taken by the
characters so let's go through some of
the ways that an author can develop
theme within a story with the important
caveat that you won't always be able to
detect a theme in a text until you're
already finished reading it for the
first time this to me is one of the
great pleasures of rereading you've
already worked hard to get an
understanding of the text so now you can
go back and pick up all the stuff you
might not have noticed the first time so
one way to develop theme is through the
repeated use of a symbol or an object
the ring in Lord of the Rings is a great
example because characters are always
talking about it but it can really be
anything a design an object an animal
imagine a story about a child who wants
to grow up to be an engineer that
develops airplanes and throughout this
story Birds keep showing up birds on the
protagonist's windowsill her favorite
teachers bird earrings maybe she has a
best friend named Robin and from that we
can see the idea of flight
is a theme in this story and all of
these bird related things go back to
this characters desire to take flight
changes in setting are a fine way to
develop themes how is a location
portrayed how does it match with the way
characters feel or behave when they
appear in these locations imagine a
character who desperately wants to be
alone so at a tense portion in the story
she flees to a distant mountaintop when
she gets there what's the weather like
is it cold snowy and forbidding on the
mountain is it an active volcano
bubbling with lava is it clear
peaceful full of snowdrops and mountain
goats what would an author be trying to
say with those decisions how should we
the reader feel about that characters
solitude if it's snowy and forbidding is
that a symbol of the characters coldness
of their hardening up does the volcano
reflect the characters explosive
potential or does the beauty of the
lonely mountaintop mean this was the
right decision for the character to take
dialogue that repeatedly references a
similar idea can be a way to develop
theme when characters mentioned
something a lot it's probably because
the author is thinking about it and
maybe wanted to build it intentionally
into the story
imagine a teenager in ancient Rome who's
preoccupied with honor and his family
name and how he's worried he won't live
up to the achievements of his ancestors
if that's something that he's insecure
about he might think about it often or
talk about the concept of honor or the
social standing of his family you can
also see this presented as explicit
lessons by a sage character usually
older and wise think of mallanna's
grandmother or of Yoda they'll say
something explicit like go do the thing
your heart wants Moana or trust that the
energy of the universe will make you a
really good space wizard Luke I'm
paraphrasing here or think of Dorothy in
The Wizard of Oz saying there's no place
like home
she says it again and again the words
are so powerful that they're used as a
magic spell and word so powerful that
they become magic is really just another
way to say theme
it doesn't need to be said allowed to be
thematic some of the most powerful
moments in storytelling come from action
not just dialogue momentous character
decisions like Maui giving up his powers
to save Moana or Harry Potter's
climactic battle with Voldemort are
chock-full of themes self-sacrifice the
power of love the importance of honesty
some of these themes can be expressed
without speaking a single word and I
should be clear sometimes you need to
finish the story before you can look
back on it and understand how parts of
it contribute to the theme you might
need to get some distance before you can
see how all of the pieces fit together
if something really sticks with me
sometimes I like to go back and reread
parts of a book once I've gotten a sense
of its theme to see how the author has
threaded theme through the text now if
you look very closely at the videos I
make here at Khan Academy if you really
squint your eyes and listen carefully
you'll notice that all of them share the
same theme which is you can learn
anything Dave it out